so
let's face it the threat of hydrogen
bomb warfare is the greatest danger our
nation has ever known
enemy jet bombers carrying nuclear
weapons can sweep over a variety of
routes and drop
bombs on any important target in the
united states
the threat of this destruction has
affected our way of life in
every city town and village from coast
to coast
these are the signs of the time
only in practice now a rehearsal a
training exercise
but tomorrow this siren may mean the
real thing
and if you hear it as you drive in your
auto
as you sit in your office or work at
your bench
wherever you are what will you do
what will happen to you
let's face it your life
the fate of your community and the fate
of your nation depends
on what you do when enemy bombers head
for our cities
and that is why civil defense was
organized
to teach you how to survive in the
thermonuclear age
by taking shelter or by evacuating your
area
as directed civil defense will teach
you how to take care of yourself your
family
and neighbors how to get official
instructions and act according to plan
in time of atomic attack the usual
professional services
police fire welfare hospital and
ambulance
could be bombed out too busy or unable
to get to you and your family
civil defense control points would
function as the nerve centers for
dispatch
of organized assistance to disaster
areas from outside the target districts
every preparation is being made to deal
with emergency conditions which would be
created by
enemy attack to provide for
communication with the public during an
actual attack
our broadcasting industry and the
federal government develop conrad
this system permits the broadcasting of
official news and civil defense
instructions without helping enemy
navigators find our cities by following
radio beams
the conrad frequencies are 640
and 1240 on your standard radio dial
a hazard unique to nuclear warfare is
radioactive fallout
unseen unheard and odorless this
substance can only be detected
with sensitive instruments special
training is necessary for radiological
safety experts
their duties will be to check radiation
levels in both damaged areas and
probable fallout areas
when sufficient warning time can be
obtained by early detection of
approaching enemy aircraft
withdrawal from key target cities or
fallout areas
may be ordered by local civil defense
authority
the instinct of survival is inherent in
all of us
and national survival requires that each
one of us
assume his share of the responsibility
there is work to be done
and each must cooperate opportunities
for training with the red cross and
other groups are everywhere
the combined efforts of many trained
individuals are needed to make civil
defense
a forceful reality this training is
invaluable in preparation for
enemy attack or the savage fury of
nature
experience in past disasters has proved
the value
of advanced training and the need for
more stockpiling of emergency food
supplies
medicines and other critical items to
care for the injured and homeless
however it was the awesome power of
atomic energy as demonstrated
in wartime use that brought to sharp
focus the new problems concerning
human survival and the urgent need for a
civil defense program
based on facts about the atomic bomb
opportunities to gain this information
came with the study of structures and
controlled atomic tests
conducted at any weetark at all in the
central pacific
the main objective of testing is weapons
development
to strengthen national security but also
included are scientific experiments for
the atomic energy commission
military projects for the air force army
and navy
and defense tests for the federal civil
defense administration
primarily concerned with the effects of
nuclear weapons on cities
industries and people the tremendous
effects of heat and blast on modern
structures raise important questions
concerning their durability and safety
likewise the amount of damage done to
our
industrial potential will have a serious
effect upon our ability to recover from
an atomic attack
transportation facilities are vital to a
modern city
the nation's lifeblood could be cut if
its traffic arteries were suffered
these questions are of great interest
not only to citizens in metropolitan
centers
but also to those in rural areas who may
be in a danger zone because of
radioactive fallout from today's larger
weapons
we could get many of the answers to
these questions by constructing a
complete city at our nevada proving
ground
and then exploding a nuclear bomb over
it
we could study the effects of damage
over a wide area
under all conditions and plan civil
defense measures accordingly
but such a gigantic undertaking is not
feasible
instead we build representative units of
a test city
with steel and stone and brick and
mortar
with precision and skill as though it
were to last a thousand years
but it's a weird fantastic city a
creation right out of science fiction
a city like no other on the face of the
earth
homes neat and clean and completely
furnished that will never be occupied
bridges massive girders of steel
spanning the empty desert
railway tracks that lead to nowhere for
this is the end of the line
but every element in these tests is
carefully planned as to its design and
location in the area
a variety of materials and building
techniques are often represented in a
single structure
every break beam and board will have its
story to tell
when pieced together these will give
some of the answers
and some of the information we need to
survive in the nuclear age
at varying distances from ground zero
the point of detonation
numerous experimental elements are
assembled
underground structures and facilities of
various types
play their part in duplicating the
complexity of the modern city
the vast research program includes
testing such items as covering materials
paints varnishes plastics also various
fabrics and samples of clothing
on the outskirts of our test city a
synthetic forest has been erected to
determine the protective value of
foliage and trees
to give us a ringside view of the event
high-speed cameras stand
like lonely sentinels ready to
photograph the hurricane of fury
before leaving the test area a final
check is made on the multitude of
instruments and technical devices which
will record a variety of blast phenomena
for future study
now with all the elements in place our
test city is complete
from the air its center will appear as a
bullseye to the bombardier
at hr
on the morning of shot day official
observers technicians
and scientists gather at news knob to
await the momentous event
this is the payoff for months of
planning and preparation on the part of
the atomic energy commission
the military services civil defense and
other test agencies
as part of an experiment to observe the
phenomenon of atomic detonation
at close hand military personnel and
defense officials dig in within a few
miles of ground
zero after a final briefing from the
officer in charge
just before h hour the men disappear
into their foxholes
every precaution has been taken for
their safety
they're told to crouch low shield their
eyes and remain
down until the signal to rise is given
now the moment of greatest anxiety
waiting
those last few seconds
seconds later the blast wave reaches the
trenches
as the tower of smoke and flame looms
overhead one thought is uppermost in all
mines
now it's over the fury of it had stunned
some but not one was injured
high above the smoke ring puffed by
atomic breath
rises skyward watched by the men who had
faced a scouting party takes the first
look at the scattered wreckage of the
test city
the imprint left by the hurricane of
fire and blast remains here for us to
read
and analyze from studies of ruins and
damage such as this
we get the hard to come by knowledge
that helps us form rules
for survival in modern warfare
while only atomic bombs are tested in
nevada the results can be scaled for the
larger
far more powerful thermonuclear weapons
a hydrogen bomb will destroy a greater
area than the atomic bomb
and will release more dangerous
radioactive materials
but the problems of rescue caused by
blast and fire along the periphery of
damage remain the same
in these fringe areas civil defense
training can save many lives
lessen damage from secondary fires and
help establish
emergency facilities now in a helicopter
the radiological safety men measure the
amount of radiation
when readings indicate safety for human
beings the troops are led in for a tour
of the area
by double checking with geiger counters
every inch of the route
men can now enter safely and confidently
areas spotted with radiological
contamination
an indication of the progress made in
understanding atomic hazards
and thus each test adds to our growing
fund of knowledge
for it is only by investigating and
experimenting that we get the facts to
keep our military and civil defense
program
up to date and effective every bit of
twisted steel makes
its contribution blackened ruins and
ashes of a structure
at another chapter the shattered
wreckage of a dwelling
offers an eloquent testimonial piece by
piece
like the parts of a jigsaw puzzle our
story is assembled
analyzed and evaluated then the survival
facts are made available to you
through your local civil defense program
in the thermonuclear age civil defense
like military defense must be flexible
it must develop and grow even as the
forces that threaten our existence
and so until men of good will have
turned this awesome power
to peaceful uses let us recognize the
threat to our way of life
the threat to our survival and
let's face it
you